2013's Thor the Dark World finds Loki
imprisoned in Asgard following the
events of the Avengers while this sequel
is frequently criticized audiences did
get something they'd been wanting a less
evil Loki in fact that's what Tom Heston
wanted as well in a 2013 interview with
total film magazine Heston explained
when I met Alan Taylor director of Dark
World he asked me how I thought I could
do Loki again without repeating myself
and I remembered talking with Kevin
feige when we were on the Avengers
promotional tour I said okay you've seen
Thor and Loki be antagonistic for two
films now it would be amazing to see
them fight side by side